this is the perfect crowd to premiere
this in front of the energy must have
been incredible can you describe what it
was like oh it was hall h was incredible
uh it was exhilarating if i could choose
one word it would be exhilarating
and you get to share this experience
with you 22 other
people that you made this with it must
have been crazy to be able to be here
together
it's it's
i can't even tell you how it feels after
two years of being a new zealand mid
pandemic making this rapping a year ago
and then here we are today and it just
feels surreal but also
i can't wait to it's we're ready we're
ready to share this with the world i bet
you know i watched the trailer earlier
today and i got chills being someone
who's loved the lord of the rings for a
while how often would you be on set in
costume going wow wow like i can't
believe this right now the attention to
detail our costume designer kate hawley
is a genius
a certified bonafide genius she is um
she had this thing called a war room if
you went into it she had just sort of
like a whole tolkien universe um in
costumes and she is such a magical huge
part of this uh of creating this world
and the attention to detail from the art
department to the greens department to
construction to costume design hair
makeup everything was extraordinary that
when you set foot on those sets in the
character it was a pinch me moment
really was there anything from your
wardrobe that you thought i could make
this work for a night out
probably not
quite dirty
muddy
um
but i i do have something i took away
her um hairpiece as a as a memento so i
would rock that i would rock the
hairpiece you have to have something you
got to take something yeah now we know
this is like the most expensive
show that's ever been made and it's all
we can see it on the screen
is that also reflected at the craft
table
oh yeah oh yeah we we um did get
together it took us a bit it took us a
moment but we got there you know
um
i think there's so many people to feed
how i mean it was like something like a
900 person crew so
um yeah i think there was no no nothing
spared we ever we were so well taken
care of beautiful who from the cast of
the original trilogy would you love to
know would become a fan of your show
ah all of them i would hope i would hope
um
kate blanchett for for more ford's sake
and and um you know all of the the ogs i
would say uh who who are represented now
as characters in our show i would hope
that they approve and enjoy um the sort
of this reincarnation of those roles i'm
sure they will thank you so much for the
time thank you
you